so
we are live
hey and uh welcome to our last workshop
of our enterprise scale nlp workshop
series with amazon search maker
um we will wait just a few minutes
feel free to say hello in the chat
where are you from and what you are
interested in today's workshop
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we have people from india wow
what time is it over there
[Laughter]
you're crazy thank you thanks for
joining amazing
and lots of different places yeah that's
awesome
11 31 pm oh come on
that's dedication
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
australia 4 a.m okay okay all right
that's not now this one's
all right i think you win
yeah i am i might need to change like
the slide i think it's not anymore the
10th for you
yeah yeah yeah he's ahead
all right
[Music]
wow it's it's really a global audience i
mean it's you know us
all over europe
india australia bangladesh
egypt estonia nice
all right mexico
nice great i think we can start and then
for everyone who is joining uh a bit
later it's not an issue since we're just
going through the instruction step and
for those of you who have like already
attended the first workshop and the
second workshop i think which just will
be like
a reputation in any ways so yeah welcome
to the dml ops uh end-to-end titling
phase transformers uh with the hub and
sagemaker pipelines workshop so what we
are going to do is we are going to use
the stage maker pipeline um service to
create an end-to-end machine learning
pipeline where we have different steps
for processing training evaluation and
then deployment of course and we will go
through each step with all of use and
you will all have the option to run
the notebook side by side
and
to
who's joining with me today so we have
nate again who will keep an eye on the
chat so if you have any questions feel
free to write them into the chat we will
like go through all of them while doing
the session then we have joining julian
simon
our chief evangelist and then myself and
mature from aws
and then in addition we have a new
release discord where we have like a
dedicated hugging face stage maker
channel so if you have any questions
after the workshop or in the next couple
of weeks
join our discord happy to connect you
there and then we have also a nice forum
where you can ask questions
to transformers to aws to sagemaker and
of course all of the material we are
going to show and what we have used in
the last two workshops is available on
github
then matune feel free to take over yes
thanks i will share my screen
for those i've already added them to the
previous workshop you already know about
sagemaker and the benefit of it so today
i want to focus more on the reinvent
that is uh celebrating the 10 years
this year and it's like the big
conference of amazon to present
uh the the new products
and especially uh
them that is around
the iml
so
i prepared just couple of uh slides to
present like the my selection of uh
obsession that you can watch during the
the event
so the first one will be the keynote
from
from swami that is the vice president of
amazon machine learning and so it
happened on the 3rd of december
we have
the peter's keynote around the
infrastructure and maybe we'll hand on
some new hardware for machine learning
so i encourage you to join that and to
extend a bit uh we have a
adam the new ceo of aws that will
present the global keynote
and after that the reinvent is like
three days of uh learning uh so you can
join breakout session uh
a duggars depressor that is a a
competition of the iml uh self-diving
vehicle and
an atom to some training and
certification
uh
of course we have a negative phase
dedicated station
on the 29th of november so i encourage
you to to join there
and also a couple of sessions that i put
on the side
around machine learning deep learning
tensorflow 8 by torch that may interest
you
so that is for the re invent and feel
free to uh to go to uh reinvent that uh
iws events that come to register it's
free
to accent to access the the
virtualization
and so uh today uh for that workshop we
will access again to another google
second to uh
to let you the possibility to follow us
and access to some computer resources so
on the chat philip should have
shared the the dashboard that event
engine that run
url where you copy past the ash
in the the field box and you click login
there you can sign up using the email
one-time password
click on it put your email address
i will erase it on my phone
and you will be redirected to uh the
team dashboard
where you so that the event is not
running so we'll just start it
right now
and read the page
so there you can access the adobe s
console
and click on the link open modules
console
you will be radiated
with credential inside the adobe glass
console
if it works
i already
look from somewhere else
okay no problems
that's it
and from there you can select stage
maker here or type on the
on the search box
to access the service
here we are already uh instantiate some
number some notebook for you so you
click netboot instance
and here you have a formant book because
you will be for assigned to the same
icons so please
pick one of them and you see at the
beginning you have blue green yellow and
red so i will take
the blue one
and click open jupiter
from the jupiter notebook we will go
through the the workshop free mlaps
so when you come here just check if you
have no uh notebook running because it
may
seems that someone else take the icon
before you and so you can just go back
uh to the search maker console and take
another one you can see also that when
you load the notebook and the notebook
will be green there so you just have to
open it
and we already prepare all the code for
you so you can select one version of uh
buy torch there or python
at least
and uh
and you have your notebook running so
when it's done you have the green
book there and you see that it's running
so please make sure that you don't use
the same notebook
of someone else
and during that presentation we will go
through the sage maker playing plank
that you can see
through the the sagemaker studio so to
access the studio you can go to search
maker domain and studio there
and
click
launch app studio and from there you
will have a
around two minutes to start the studio
and philippe and junior will guide you
on that
so
[Music]
it's finished for me so you can take the
end
all right so okay uh i hope all of you
um
already started to get access to your
stage maker account if you are joining
late and don't have access feel free to
like send a chat message then nate will
share the event engine link again
and
what we will do like as first step is
like not begin at the top as we would
usually do since we want to show you the
result or like how the the pipeline um
is run so the first step we are going to
do is to execute a pipeline uh it takes
around 30 minutes so um close before the
end we can then um see the results of
the pipeline and now we go back like to
the
to the main pipeline and as matthew
already said so you will share your aws
account potentially with different
participates and you have like your
notebook yellow green blue and please
change your or the end so suffix to like
the notebook you are running in because
we are creating like different aws
services and resources which has
names applied to and if um people are
going to create like the resource with
the same id one of you would see an
arrow so change the g suffix to like the
notebook color you are basically running
in
okay so then the first step um
since we are using uh i'm alone i'm
using the red one and then we are going
to install the latest stage maker uh sdk
to make sure that we have all required
the packages we need for
hanging fails for transformers for the
sagemaker pipelines installed and then
we have basically a huge chunk of
imports which are basically importing
everything we need to create our
pipeline so the stagemaker pipeline
yeah consists out of multiple different
steps so we have like a step for
processing a step for training and we
are importing all of those
and then of course to like
get running to do things of aw in aws
you always need permission and the
sagemaker or the notebook environment
provides a nice feature and
functionality then you can directly
assume a role which is provided by the
instance running so we can execute a
cell and i think we are now like ready
to get started and in the beginning we
have like a nice pipeline overview and
julian will like guide you through it
what we do basically
yeah so
you know we try to to replicate
something that's pretty typical so of
course first we have a
data a data processing job to to process
the data set
and uh so that's the
for the first step of the pipeline
loading the loading the data processing
it
then we have a training step of course
when we train the model um and
sometimes your training goes well
sometimes it doesn't so it's
important to check the evaluation metric
and so we have a an evaluation step
where we look at
the the output from the training job and
if if accuracy is good enough then we go
and deploy
uh if it's not then we just you know we
kind of uh don't go further okay so
assuming the the training uh went well
and the metric is fine then we go and
deploy
and uh here we use a slightly different
technique i guess
uh we're not deploying to a stage maker
endpoint we're deploying
um
we're deploying with the lambda function
right so we are deploying to an endpoint
but we are using a lambda function to do
it uh where which is an interesting way
to show you the the lambda step okay
and in between there's the a
registration step
where we actually create the model in
the the sagemaker model registry and the
model registry is a way for you to
version your models
and uh and and deploy them uh using
different techniques but this time
because i think philip is a is a lambda
fan and uh well so am i
we we decided to show you the lambda way
okay
yeah so
so currently or what search maker
pipeline provides is like as truly
mentioned is this different steps and to
be able to deploy there's like no
official like sage maker pipeline step
to create a endpoint and what we like
wanted to have is of course like the
full experience like automatically
running your training which is like
triggered by us maybe or through another
lambda or maybe an event engine event
which is like um like a crown shop or
something and then of course since we
have like this condition inside of it we
are sure that we are like not deploying
a garbage model that's why we added like
this automated step using a lambda to
create like
the endpoint itself
and just just a quick comment on that so
you
you know you could use pipelines for
i would say development workflows
experimentation workflows and and i
guess this is what we're doing today so
we actually want to deploy and test
in our own vpc in our own account
but you can also use it strictly for
production in a fully automated way so
let's say you know this pipeline is
really running completely
automatically
maybe we you know launched it
automatically
and and then um you would want to have
the model in the model registry
uh with a validation status and then
another workflow would go and take that
model and probably deploy it in a
different vpc or maybe in a different
aws account maybe and maybe you have
manual validation so that's why the
model registry is really central
uh and and you could go and grab the
artifact and deploy it somewhere else
okay but again today we're going like
philipp said we're going end-to-end
because
i want to show you the whole story
exactly and i zoomed a bit in i hope
it's now better and of course like the
pipeline has a lot of like um
configuration steps and different steps
and what we are going to do is basically
define like in step zero since we are
like all computer science uh fanatica um
our like pipeline parameters and we have
a parameter for like all of our
artifacts so the pipeline or like the
scripts we are going to use inside of
the pipeline will be stored in s3 so
that's we have our s3 prefix we define
our bucket where we want to save like
the model output the artifacts we have
our region to make sure that we are like
running in the same environment since
like as julian mentioned we could like
train on us east one because they have
like the p4 instance and we want to like
run huge gpu training and then since we
are like globally active we want to
deploy like across the globe into
different aws yeah that's another
scenario absolutely
to like europe um like asia
africa so that's something you could
also do that's why we're defining the
region and we also say that like our all
of our jobs are basically containing the
same name of our s3 prefix we make sure
that we are like um caching only for a
certain amount of time since the test
and then we have like all the um hugging
phase specific i think parameters so we
want to use the latest transformers
version with the latest python version
with
like a high enough python version and
then in our example or in the pipeline
we are going to create we are going to
use the digital bird model and the imdb
dataset
and if you want to change it or if you
want to use this pipeline for like a
future project or at work and you don't
use the distributor the imvp data set
you can basically change the parameter
here and then like go through the whole
pipeline and then it works the same so
that's like what's really nice about it
that you are like creating the pipeline
once for like the text classification
task in this case and then you are like
uh able to like change it up with the
different models we provide through the
hiking phase hub so we execute our
configuration yeah and just just a quick
comment uh and so the the workflow
itself
so the pipeline itself can have
parameters and that's what you see
you know the parameter string objects in
in that cell
so um so you can actually build very
generic pipelines that run
across different models across different
data sets
with different hyper parameters you know
who knows but uh yeah so the the
just like cloud formation template just
like everything else
um
you want to build pipelines that you can
reuse over a wide range
of applications right so these are what
those parameter strings
uh are it's a really really important
concept
yeah so like as julie mentioned we
define in each step those parameters and
then like before executing it we can
override them or like adjust and that
something we will see at the end that
you will probably see like the the name
for processing instance type or like the
model id at the end again before like
executing and it's like a really nice
way to have like one pipeline and then
to configure it how you want and then
our first step is going to be the
processing step and currently the
hacking phase dlc are only available for
training and for gpu so what we are
going to do we are of course going to
use like the most familiar uh machine
learning library out there which is
cycle learn which has a nice cycle
processor
and then we are creating our um
processor and then we have a processing
step so each like step inside of the
sagemaker pipeline is a step stage maker
the sdk provides a lot of like pre
existing steps for processing of
training and then later we will see how
we like use the lambda step to to do our
um our custom step and then we provide
locate which transformers we want to use
we have our model id and data set again
which we have defined a bit earlier and
then of course since we want to save the
data set files afterwards and use it for
training we define our outputs
which will be then saved to s3 of course
and can be accessed by like the next
step so these output parameters we are
defining here will be accessed inside
the next step yeah a quick comment on on
the syntax here uh so some of you may be
familiar with uh sagemaker processing
right which is a batch
uh the batch capability in sagemaker and
if you're familiar with them if that you
can see it's exact same syntax right
that sklearn processor definition is
exactly the same
and and in fact um
that that's i when you start automating
i i recommend that you first
um
build the the the scaler and the um
sagemaker processing steps
independently and and then you can start
combining them in the with the pipeline
syntax um you can literally cut and
paste because sometimes you know writing
the pipeline from scratch is a little
bit too much right it's uh it's a little
bit both it can be a little confusing so
start by defining all the steps
individually just like you would run
them manually in uh in the notebook
and you know the estimator and the
sagemaker processing steps etc and and
then you can very easily combine them
with the pipelines because again the
syntax is 99 identical
yeah that's exactly what we are going to
see like in the next step which is the
training step um since we are using a
disability that's the last description
to what this albert is
and then we have again our parameter for
which like entry point we are going to
use and the hyper parameter and if we
scroll down a bit and i guess you will
see something familiar for those of you
who have who have used targeting phase
before so we are going to use the hiking
phase estimator where we provide our
entry point our script and you basically
that's that's the code you might have
already written in your like default
stage maker training exactly and what we
would do there is like our hiking phase
estimated on fit to execute our training
step and to use it inside of stage maker
pipeline we are creating our training
step which will then execute the dot fit
method behind the scenes and similar to
our
fit method where we can provide our data
set when calling it we have our inputs
here which are from our process step
the output for training and then of
course the s3 ur so this this the string
here is the output of the step we run
before and we provide it into the next
step and this is how you automatically
automatically change the steps right
because
if one output
becomes an input then you kind of know
which step goes first
um
there's also a way to explicitly
uh create dependencies
um there's a there's a parameter called
depends on in in the steps you'll find
that in the sdk
where you can you can force
uh
the order of steps
um you know sometimes you want
sequential things and and it's not
obvious how you can connect them using
outputs and inputs so you can also force
dependencies but generally yeah this is
the really the best way to do it
yes and maybe something we haven't
mentioned so i saw like arrow is already
like a few steps ahead of us and saw a
warning um you will have access to the
temporary accounts longer than the
workshop so they will be available like
two to three hours after the workshop is
done so you can like really focus now on
like understanding what searchmaker
pipeline is and how you can create it
and then after it was you can still
execute a pipeline or change things up a
bit with replacing the model id or the
data set and then run it again so you
don't need to rush like through the
example to see what the end result is
and yeah json get has been renamed so
it's it's no big deal it's uh
it lives in a different place and uh
and the first parameter has changed as
well but yeah it's it's okay don't worry
about it
it'll work
yeah
and like of course after training we
want to evaluate our model and um i can
like jump into the evaluation script
since it's like located in scripts
evaluate and then like so normally what
you would expect is that we like load
our model and then like run it against
some some testing data set but since we
have done it inside our trade method
what we are going to do here is just
like looking into our model artifact
loading our evaluation change json and
then like creating or providing the
output for our accuracy to sagemaker so
if you like run a training without
evaluation inside of it or if you want
to like have a valid data set and the
test data set you want to like run
additional verification or evaluation
that's something you could do here but
in our case we are like just loading the
json file and extracting the evaluation
which we already have done
yeah in this case you we have the json
file right it's it's part of the
it's part of the training process but
for some other algorithms i mean in the
past
what i've done is you can just create a
text file
uh or a json file in in your model
artifact right just save it next to the
model and then sagemaker will uh
archive everything in the model target
jz and then you can you can do the same
here it's just very convenient because
we do have the metrics in the json file
and that's why we need json get to go
and parse that but you can you can do
the same behavior
um by just saving extra files to the
artifact in your training script that
works too
yes and then same story as before we
have our processor and then we have here
like um like something we haven't seen
before it's like a property file that's
exactly what julia mentioned is that
since we are creating a file inside our
processing job which has some like
structure in it we want to extract this
information so we have saved it as json
file we have our json like name of it
and then like sagemaker will load it
behind the scene similar to what you
would do with python json loads and then
you have like a dictionary where you can
like really work with and then we have
like defining again our processing step
which like expects the model artifact
which includes our and model and our
evaluation json and then outputs only
the report like the the result of our
training and then like in step six we
will see like what we are going to do
with this evaluation but like for now we
like continue with the creation of the
pipeline and expecting or like assuming
that the training would have been
successfully and the metrics are good
enough to deploy our model
and first step what we do is like
register our model maybe julian can say
a bit more about what what does it mean
yeah so so this is really something
something new that sagemaker pipelines
brought i mean
before sagemaker pipeline was available
in sagemaker you would
you would train right so you would call
estimator dot fit get your uh training
job going
and you would have your model artifact
in s3
and then
and then you would
create the model which would really
make it visible in sagemaker for
deployment and then you would deploy
the model registry goes a little bit
further as you can see uh the parameters
for a register model include
content types response types
um instance types
which means you can actually restrict uh
the the list the the the type of
instances
for endpoints and for batch transform
um so that's super useful because this
means no one can deploy this to
something else so
for example in the testing
scenario you know you would want to
deploy on very tiny instances because
you know they don't need to scale
and for production you could make sure
that you know you do use let's say gpu
instances and that no one accidentally
deploys to cpu instances because
prediction would be slow for for this
particular model you know that kind of
thing and then and then you have the
approval status so in this case again we
made it simple we set it to approved
but you can send you can set it to
pending manual approval okay
and this means that until
the status has been changed manually
you cannot deploy the model so coming
back to what i was saying before
um that's typically what you would use
in a production scenario right when you
have an automated job running
um
an automated pipeline running
registering the model and then maybe the
data sounds team looks at the model run
some tests
look at the evaluation metrics etc and
says yeah okay this is good to go right
and then they would change the status of
the model
and then
um you know deployment would happen and
actually changing the stages could
automatically trigger maybe a cloud
formation template that goes and deploy
you know there are many many ways to do
it but short long story short the the
model registry is really important
uh and if you use sagemaker studio which
we're not using today
you can actually browse the registry you
can see the different versions of the
model you can see approval statuses etc
so the the traceability angle is is
quite interesting we're not going to use
it today but keep that in mind right for
prod it's really
and then cool saw like two questions
coming in first off was uh what capacity
of ram is required and can you like
clarify the question a bit more like so
each step we have like run so far for
processing training and evaluation runs
on a separate ec2 instance type so for
processing since it like doesn't require
any gpu you can define like a small
cpu-based instance or if you're like
running using large data sets you can
like use a cpu compute accelerated and
if you want to like um for training go
with the gpu so your training is faster
then select the
gpu instant and same for the post
processing step and for like the whole
sagemaker pipelines like workflow
there's no like there's no need to like
um require or like to
yet to create any computer resource so
it's like completely managed
by aws so you don't need to worry about
like using it so it's like it only runs
when you running and it will stop by the
end of it
so there's like no no run capacity for
it and then the second question maybe
julian can answer it yeah so um
so the question is uh do model packages
become available in the model package
page
so uh eric i i i'm assuming you refer to
the
to the aws console
for sagemaker not studio so i believe
they do appear um uh i have to say
it makes more sense to check out
sagemaker studio and look at the
registry
because you will see uh you will see the
different versions the you know
generally the the aws console is um you
know is really for i would say ops
um and uh and studio is where you would
see a lot more
a lot more information
uh on uh for sagemaker pipelines right
um but yeah go go and check out it
should appear there
yeah so we are like definitely looking
into the studio um
like when we are like through the
notebook to see what basically what we
have created oh yeah we want to see the
the blinking lights right yes
right
graph
there's one more we'll take one more
question here um the are we using eks at
any point no no so what we are like
everything we run in the notebook in the
workshop today is like completely based
inside like the sagemaker ecosystem but
as julian mentioned these sagemaker
pipelines are like not limited to stage
maker services so what we are doing like
at the end is deploying um our model to
a sagemaker endpoint using a custom
lambda step and if like your company or
your client wants to use an eks or ec2
or ecs or like lambda to run something
you can easily like deploy it to there
and like have a lambda which executes
maybe your cdk um like project or your
cloud formation template so yeah there's
like no limitations to sagemaker yeah
yeah you could deploy to fargate if you
wanted
um you can yeah sure the lambda step is
is a very flexible way to do what
whatever you like
yeah and talking about the lambda step
since we have now like added our
register step we came to the model
deployment step and
what we have done here to like keep it
nice and simple we have created our own
model deployment step which requires uh
permission to create our end point so
every stage maker endpoint requires an
niam roll to have permission to do
things so if you are like using a model
um
like um stored on s3 the
shmaker endpoint needs permission to
load the model from s3 to like deploy it
so we have created our like model
deployment class which we're going to
take a look in a second where we have
our model name which will be used for
the endpoint and the configuration then
we have of course the the registered
model so we know which model we want to
use which is the output from our step
before
then we have the instance type we are
going to use the g4 dnx large so which
is a gpu-backed instance and we can use
it because we have defined the instance
type in our irigister model up here then
we have our im permission which will be
applied to the sagemaker endpoint so
it's not applied to the lambda function
we will use it's applied to the endpoint
itself
and then um we also have included like
in auto scaling um attribute which you
could then like define your auto scaling
um
policy but since we are like not going
that much into detail today it's like
just on on and then if we like go back
into the workshop we have
a folder called utils which has deploy
handler in the deploy step the deploy
step is our custom stage maker pipeline
step and the deploy handler is the
lambda function we are going to deploy
and if we take a look at a deploy step
it's like
a python class
using the step collection as space we
have our input parameters and then what
you can see is we are creating those
helpful lambda function using um the
code from our deploy handler and then we
are executing our lambda step with the
parameter we passed into earlier so it's
basically just an abstraction class to
automate things easier
and keep it nice and simple and then you
could like if you need like um custom
steps you could also like use unit tests
to make sure everything works
so there's a good question on
on cost and it's always it's always
important for uh
for everybody right
so the question is is there a difference
in cost between the deployment with
lambda compared to the other deployment
types so
to
just let let me clarify so here we are
not
deploying the model on a lambda function
okay we are using a lambda function
to create an endpoint
okay so that that's a difference so
the fact that we use a lambda step
versus
uh some other step makes no makes no
difference okay
um
so
i guess the bigger question would be
is there a different
is is there a difference
in cost when you deploy to
a la to actual uh to a lambda function
uh when you deploy to stage maker
endpoint or when you deploy to ecs or
when you deploy to eks etc etc so
there's no general answer to this okay
um
i i guess
deploying to a lambda function is is
interesting um
although you know uh as far as i know
there still isn't gpu support on lambda
maybe one day
um
and and lam does have the you know they
have cold start
so
for testing small models why not
i mean i've seen a lot of people using
like small scikit-learn models or
xj boost models and that works pretty
nicely on lambda for deep learning it's
more complicated because you have a
maximum size
for the lambda package and fitting your
dependencies in there is next to
impossible so you have to go and do
stupid tricks like using temporary
storage on the lambda in the lambda
container blah blah blah and
there are blog posts out there they're
very hacky so fine go and have fun but
honestly i wouldn't do it in production
and then if you use uh you know if you
use ecs or eks you know you could use
spot instances
so if you if you manage the possibility
of spot interruptions
you can go and and and do that
uh it's a little bit more work but it's
uh it's doable and it would be
more cost effective than sagemaker
but stage recurrent points
uh
bring additional capabilities right like
model monitoring you know drift
detection
uh capturing data etc etc so
it's it's apple to oranges really uh so
you have to go and understand what your
use cases are you strictly in a dev
environment and you want minimal cost or
are you in production where you want you
know auto scaling and and high
availability and all the machine
learning goodies like modern monitor etc
so it's a it's a really there's no
there's no simple answer to that but
just to give you some perspective
yeah and and something maybe to add so
you can see here that's our lambda
function which will be executed the code
and we are like using our model defining
the endpoint configuration with the
instance type and then creating the
endpoint and
i guess you don't see any inference code
here so what's very special about the
high phase experience on sagemaker is
that you can deploy any of the
transformer compatible models with any
nlt tasks so we have trained our model
on text classification with the imdb
dataset and the digital bird model and
we haven't defined any inference code
anywhere that's like handled by stage
maker behind the scenes in the inference
toolkit so if you would like go to a
different solution or maybe have on
premise servers or like something else
you also would need to write this code
yourself
and as julian said like model monitoring
or like scaling like in the last
workshop maybe for those who haven't
participated definitely check out the uh
the recording it's on youtube there we
like went through how you can auto scale
based on requests coming in with like
just a few lines of code you will be
able to like scale your endpoint from
one instance type to like four or five
and without like any heavy lifting so
you don't need to ask like your devops
or infrastructure team to create
scalable solutions
yeah generally i think you know if
you're if you're a data scientist and
you don't uh you know you don't
particularly love devops which which is
fine you know
i guess devops engineers don't
particularly love machine learning so it
goes both ways
if you want a simple way to to train and
deploy models
without messing with servers and vpcs
and ssh keys and subnets and all that
good stuff
sagemaker is the simplest option right
um
if you
if you really want to get your training
and deployment going and experiment i
think that's uh that's a good way right
and it works for production as well but
you know if you're if you're a data
scientist and you want to you know you
have to create docker clusters all you
know all of the sudden it
your your day is isn't turning very well
i think
i love docker but when you do machine
learning you want to do machine learning
and that's what sagebreaker does
and then like to answer case question
the deployment lender also can update
the endpoint with the new uh version so
yeah as you can see we are like passing
in um the output from our registration
steps so if we would re-run the whole
pipeline again and change like maybe a
hyper parameter or line run it for
longer training or change our threshold
then it would like deploy the new model
to sagemaker and that's like done since
we are like providing the new um like
model artifact from the registration and
then it will create the end point and i
think now it's like the last step in our
pipeline but which is like the fourth
step in our like pipeline is that the
like the conditional dejected okay we
run the evaluation and now do we like
register our model in the registry and
do we want to deploy it and therefore we
have again defined a parameter uh with
like a default fresh one for 0.8 we can
change it and here we have like what
julia mentioned before like the
conditionals that we are using greater
than or equal
and then we have a left side and a right
side and our left side is the the um
like the evaluation accuracy from our
json file we have saved in the
evaluation step and the right side is
our threshold so if the value in our
json we have created during training and
evaluation is created or equal to 0.8 we
are going to execute our registration
step and our deployment step
and you can ignore the warning as julian
said it has like moved so it's like
just something
don't worry about it
exactly and since we have now defined
our parameter and we talked a bit about
the like the parameters we use anywhere
we can override them so we have defined
them in each step i think it's like so
if you want to change a parameter for a
specific step go to like the step and
then see okay which parameter i have
available and i can change it and here
what i do is change the threshold to 0.7
since uh maybe it's like something above
70 is like a good starter and i want to
make sure that my pipeline runs and the
model is deployed to run a few tests and
then i can change it afterwards to like
zero point nine and a nine and then run
again and we also want to run our
training for free epoch change the
training batch size since we know okay
digital bird is not that big and we can
fit a bigger batch size into it and then
we have our pipeline here which accepts
all of the default parameters all of our
steps so here we have the processing
step the training step the evaluation
step and then the condition step which
includes the nested step from
registration and deployment so it's like
not like um one hierarchy level it's
like nested so if you have a condition
step in a condition step it's also
possible
yep
and then we can like put out the json
pipeline definition which is um
something you can copy and deploy from
somewhere else so you could use python
to create your pipeline since it's very
like nice to write the code to create a
creative thing and then if you like want
to like bring it into a different
environment or need to be compliant with
some internal guidelines you could use
the add the output and then deploy it
using infrastructure as code service and
now we are back to where we started
where we can um upset like create or
update our pipeline and then run the
pipeline with our pipeline parameters
and i think now it's like almost 30
minutes over we can jump into studio all
right
but you all of them should have a studio
available right
yep it is the same for everyone but uh
yeah the the studio is there so you just
have to wait like closely two minutes to
to have it set up if it's not already
there
and and yeah you have access to it
do you have directions on getting to
that uh philip
um yeah we have like also on the left
side in the search maker menu where we
open the notebook instance there should
be studio and then you should see
something in the middle of the screen
running and then you can like click on
the right side on launch
i mean i can like also
quickly jump into it i think
thanks i think it'll just help clarify
for some folks yes
we have searchmaker here
and before we went into notebook and
notebook instances to run our notebook
and now we have studio here where you
should see
a user or the app running and then you
can go and launch app and then click on
studio which will open
a new tab
and then we are in sagemaker studio
and compared to to the notebook instance
we used searchmaker studio provides yeah
more insights to different stage maker
services we have on the left side um we
have two new navigation can you zoom in
a little bit
i'm afraid it's it's a bit small
or maybe i need bigger i need new
glasses but
okay yeah all right i'm better thanks
yeah then we have with one section for
jump starts which are like basically um
solutions you can deploy from the
beginning and then we have um all of the
stage maker resources with projects
pipelines module registry which julian
talked a bit about earlier our endpoints
we have deployed and then of course our
pipeline and
i run the pipeline before and then we
have created another one when starting
the workshop which was 36 minutes ago
and it successfully run already and here
we can see
all of the steps which has been run so
we have our processing step
and now i need to watch out a bit and on
the right side you have like the input
and output parameter we defined so here
we can see basically the parameters we
have provided through the parameter
values and of course the output and the
logs
which which are a godstand i have to say
because sometimes you know we always
make it look a little too easy but trust
me you know my pipelines never run on
the first try
so uh you know i forgot something and
it's it's red and then you know and and
i can go and check out the logs
and and and this is this is really
convenient so you can see exactly why a
step failed and you can see it inside
studio
because the alternative would be
you have to go to amazon cloud watch
which is the the monitoring service for
aws and cloud watch logs and you have to
go and find uh you know the the
particular log for the particular job
and yeah and it's not it's not fun right
so uh if your pipelines don't work
you can see it right here you can see
one of those boxes one of those steps
here would be red
and you can check out the logs and as
philip said you know you can check your
inputs uh and you could quickly figure
out why something failed right so
very very convenient
and if we check our like ebay evaluation
accuracy we have our threshold and the
default value was 0.8 and we like
overwrote it um in our parameters
dictionary before starting the instance
and here we can see it's like 0.7 so
it's like it overwrites the things we
provided and then like of course we have
the registration step and then the
deployment step and i think before like
um looking into the endpoint we can see
in the module registry we have here the
hiking phase model package group where
all of your models
should be added
and here you should see like the
different versions and exactly what
should you mention we can like jump into
it we have our approval status we have
no matrix registered yeah
yes and then we have like more settings
too um
which was used or which will be used for
inference what is where's the model
stored and the trial reruns so for
traceability like i said you know
versioning models is always difficult i
don't know how you do it but
you know a lot of people just save files
in a in an s3 bucket and they
they they they use v1 and v2 and v3 in
the in the name which is always a
recipe for disaster
so here automatically you have
versioning and and you know exactly
which
um which artifact corresponds to which
version and there's another part of the
sagemaker sdk where you can actually do
a linear tracking
so it's pretty simple you can easily
figure it out and for example you could
say you know i want for this particular
artifact i want to know which training
sets were used and which training script
were used so all the artifacts when you
use sagemaker pipelines
all the input artifacts code data algos
etc that actually go into training a
model or tracked okay so lineage
tracking is the key word you want to
look for and and this is available in
there as well automatically when you use
pipelines
and and now i went like to the endpoints
and that's something you need to change
um to run inference in the notebook we
there's like a small middle mistake in
it since we are like running on multiple
accounts we added the time stem to our
endpoint so all of you can deploy and if
you go to the endpoint you can find an
endpoint and then we need to like copy
the timestamp of it
and
jump back into our pipeline and we also
provide the link on you can like
directly jump into the percentage
management console to see our endpoint
and then you like um need to create a
timestamp and then for the endpoint name
so the endpoint name and currently on
your site should be just model id and
data set but since you're like running
on shared account we added the timestamp
to it so all of you can create the model
endpoint and then if i create my
predictor object i can run like the
predictions for the model we have here
an input for a movie um
which is
positive and then we have a an input for
um like a review basically which is
yeah not good i would say negative
and then at the end we have now also
provided some functionality like to
clean up everything again for the
temporary account it like it it's not
that important because they will like
tear down anyway but if you're like
doing it on your personal account always
make sure that like you don't
run unnecessary compute when you're not
using it and you can like just run the
last cell and everything will be deleted
so we have a question on um
on load balancing and auto scaling i
think that's an interesting point
so yes indeed the
the previous webinar was touched upon
the topic but
what kind of quick what i can quickly
explain is so sagemaker endpoints are
automatically
uh load balanced
um
and so
let me rephrase so when you deploy a
sagemaker endpoint
you specify how how many instances
uh actually back the endpoint right so i
think here we're using a single instance
but if we used
two three for instance
uh traffic is automatically load
balanced across those instances okay so
you don't have to create a load balancer
you don't have to scale the load
balancer all that stuff is built in
now if you want to scale the endpoint
itself
of course you can do it manually you can
update manually the number of instances
and you can also set up auto scaling
right so you can set an auto scaling
policy on your endpoint
and say you know whenever
whenever my
requests per second exceed this number
you know scale right um so
that's that's as much as you need to do
and um and of course
when you have multiple instances on an
endpoint they're automatically spread
across the different availability zones
right so load balancing is built in high
availability is built in
and auto scaling you can pretty easily
enable right hopes yeah answers the
questions so so if you like i just
showed the youtube video of the last
workshop and we we like really dedicated
the whole like session last time on how
to create an endpoint with similar to
what we have here one instance count one
way and then how to like add an auto
scaling group and also add an auto
scaling policy based on request and um
you can like also look at the stage
maker github repository where you are
currently like running the workshop free
in workshop two you should find lab
three which like goes through it step by
step we take a look at model monitoring
before auto scaling and after auto
scaling and i think in total to add auto
scaling to your endpoint is around like
15 lines of code which will additionally
run so it's like not that much and it
will be like applied immediately
okay are there more questions about
sagemaker pipeline
there's a question on model monitoring
um
i'm not sure i understand so i'll answer
the question the way i understand it but
please correct me if i'm wrong okay
so
sagemaker model monitoring
requires that you send individual
prediction requests okay so that means
in the payload that is sent to the
endpoint you need to have a single
instance a single
data point right
if you if you have multiple
data samples in there
data capture will work okay
but
model monitoring will fail
right so
don't ask me why
hopefully that gets
fixed at some point it's a restriction
of the service as far as i know
but yeah that's the one yeah okay thanks
omayon that's what i thought
uh so yeah that's it's it's not a bug
it's a feature
so again
data capture will work but baselining
and model monitoring will fail
because they only support
i guess you know the file format is json
lines so if you have more than one
instance per line their parser doesn't
work and somebody has to go and add that
feature so yep
hashtag aws wishlist on twitter
i
i tried
i tried to get them to implement it but
they're busy right so help me out
any more or further questions to what we
have shown you today
if you guys are going through this later
and
have any other questions or something
comes up you can join our discord i'll
send the link again here in the chat and
we can talk about it there
yeah so if you want to stay in touch i i
just posted our uh
twitter accounts um
and of course nate is on twitter i
should post nate
uh
give me a second
i'll find you
oh good i have an underscore oh okay
okay oh you have an underscore that's
why yes
it's very sad yeah so um
yeah get in touch follow us uh
keep uh keep an eye on the on the
youtube channel for more keep an eye on
the discord channel
send us feedback send us questions yeah
we're
happy to interact and uh
and share your feedback if you have aws
feedback as well on on hugging face on
sagemaker we're more than happy to read
it
and um
and get our aws friends to uh to add
more features as well right
last question we got are there any plans
for integration with google word hexai
[Laughter]
should i take this one
yeah
so short answer is no
our
our preferred partner
is
for for machine learning on the on the
cloud is currently aws uh
doesn't mean we're not uh
cooperating with everybody else uh but
for now uh yeah it's uh it's not in the
picture but there are so many other ways
you can do hogging face
in the cloud right so um you can use
containers you can use virtual machines
you know nate and all the devrel team
they have lots of demos and uh yep
and i will be adding more
okay
yep so don't worry
lots more coming i wish i could tell
great then i guess we can sign off here
like have everyone a nice day nice night
for the australian or like asian people
yeah and if it's later than
11 p.m come on that's it it's enough
it's complete please you know we feel
terrible go to bed go to bed right have
enjoy enjoy your life it's enough
citymaker for one night
[Laughter]
thank you so much thank you so much
bye
bye